oh
macron is now the dominant strain of
coveted in the united states joe biden
threatens the unvaccinated with illness
and death for christmas and the white
house gives up on joe manchin i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet i've told you over and over just do
it visit expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first if you want to be
a hero for the holidays how about
getting your loved one a new iphone and
you can do it for not all that much
money and you get a better phone plan
when you do it from puretalk puretalk
has iphone 12 starting at just 479
through the end of the year and they
have 13s as well i switched over to pure
talk i'm getting great nationwide 5g
coverage that is the same coverage as
the big guys and you can too the average
family saves over 800 a year now that's
just smart i would not tell you to use a
service i'm not completely happy with
make the switch with puretalk's 30-day
risk-free guarantee you have nothing to
lose unlimited talk text six gigs of
data just 30 bucks a month and as i said
the iphone 12 is just 479 go to
puretalk.com shop for the plan and phone
that's right for you and then enter
promo code shapiro save an additional 50
off your very first month and save on a
new phone that's puretalk.com promo code
shapiro puretalk is simply smarter
wireless some restrictions apply see
cite four details head on over to
puretalk.com
again enter promo code shapiro you'll
save an additional 50 off your very
first month of coverage and save it on a
new phone and then you'll save hundreds
of dollars down the road
puretalk.com alrighty so oh macron it's
here and you're supposed to be so scared
so super duper scared like so scared
like hide in your closet never come out
ever again wrap yourself in saran wrap
leave a little bit of a hole just for
your mouth and for your nose this is the
only way to prevent you from getting
covered and even if there's a little
hole by your mouth and your nose that's
exactly how covet gets in so the best
thing you could possibly do is then duct
tape those holes closed you won't die of
covet you might have something you won't
die of covet and that's the important
thing okay here's the thing omicron is
now the dominant variant in the united
states
the hospitals are not being overwhelmed
we are not seeing mass carnage we're not
seeing mass death we've not seen mass
death in the uk we've not seen mass
death in south africa
the evidence that omicron is anywhere
near as deadly as delta is non-existent
because it is not the lab studies
demonstrate that omicron tends to stay
around your nose and around your throat
and it does not go down into your lungs
which means that essentially for the
vast majority of people it is going to
be a cold maybe a slightly bad cold but
a cold it is not going to be the cause
of death for the vast fast fast that's a
vast majority of people who get it
in fact the statistics right now tend to
show that it is less deadly than the flu
hey like significantly less deadly than
the flu according to the stats that we
have from south africa now could those
stats change theoretically but we are
now well over a month out from the south
african variant becoming public
knowledge
and there was no uptick in death in
south africa okay so according to the
cdc the omicron variant has caused more
than 70 percent of recent coveted 19
cases in the united states
highlighting a substantial increase in
infectiousness compared with earlier
versions of the virus in many parts of
the u.s omicron now makes up more than
90 of cases according to the cdc the
cdc's updated data showed oh macron had
caused some 13 percent of recent
infections in the week through december
11th the variance is spread rapidly in
the united states it has reached at
least 89 nations around the world since
being identified in southern africa last
month new york state which again has a
lot of axe mandates and they have i mean
new york city has a vax mandate and they
have a mass mandate and um they have a
massive spike
so here is the question
why are we seeing people freak out about
a disease that has an extremely low
death rate
that is so transmissible you are not
going to be able to stop it in any
serious way without
taking my aforementioned first path
hiding yourself in a closet saran
wrapping your body and then duct taping
your your orifices
if you have no other options
then
why are we doing this stuff right and
and more than that why are we trying to
freak everybody out like what is the
evidence that we should all be freaking
out at this point
they're they're taking measures that are
not proved to work against covet and
this is the entire thing okay the the
boosters that i know people who are
triple vaxxed who have gotten omicron at
this point okay the these the boosters
may protect slightly against
breakthrough infection for ex for a
certain period of time before the
antibodies wane but generally speaking
you are not going to be able to shut
down the virus with the boosters you
know how you know this because in israel
they boosted pretty much everybody and
they still got hit with omicron
so
what exactly are we talking about here
really what are we talking about here
well the answer is that there is a
coveted cult out there it is it is now a
cult
a cult that believes infinity days to
stop the spread
and that covet cult
has one rule
you will obey
that's the rule and if you ask why you
will obey
this is a demonstration of lack of faith
because the measures that are being
taken right now have no relation to the
data on the table none we'll get some
more in just one second first ever since
i've tried my pillow my pillow is the
pillow that i use i don't use any other
form of pillow except for my pillow and
now my pillow wants to give back to our
listeners you can get great discounts on
all my pillow products if you go to
mypillow.com right now
and click on that radio listeners
special get deep discounts on my pillow
mattress toppers towels so much more for
example my pillow is offering a buy one
get one free offer on giza sheets
they're great sheets you'll love them
all my pillow products come with a
60-day money-back guarantee and a
10-year warranty go to mypillow.com
click on that radio listeners special
for the buy one get one free offer on
the giza sheets use promo code daily
wire at checkout or give them a call at
800-651-1148 that's
800-651-1148 they have all sorts of
specials available on that radio
listeners specials square when you click
on that you'll also get deep discounts
on my pillow products including pillow
slippers the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets that's
mypillow.com enter daily wire or call
1-800-651-1148
tell them dailywire send you that is
1-800-651-1148 the deals are not going
to last forever call right now they make
a great christmas gift mypillow.com
enter daily wire at checkout right now
alrighty so again everybody is freaking
out
and the goal is the freakout that is the
goal and the reason the goal is to freak
out is because
we have had the government innervate us
over the course of two long years at
this point almost two years at this
point
and the government has lied to us and
they've told us that if we only have
faith in them they will solve all of our
problems and that is an element of faith
it's an element of faith because they've
demonstrated no capacity to do this the
one thing that government did well is
they subsidized the big pharma industry
in order to create the vaccines and then
they trash those out that's what they
did well all the other things they did
badly and yet we have been told that
these government gods are going to fix
our lives
and so you have to double down on your
faith and you know what doubling down on
your faith means it means having skin in
the game so in a religious way so
there's an author named naseem nicholas
taleb
and he writes a book he has a book
called skin in the game his basic thesis
is that the reason that religious people
perform ritual is to demonstrate fealty
to the group and to the religion that's
the reason that people like me wear
yamakas is because that is an actual
sacrifice right identifying myself as
different from others and i wear the
yamaka because i am demonstrating skin
in the game right that i that i am
willing to to make a sacrifice in terms
of my personal life
in order to demonstrate field to a
particular group or ideology right that
is the idea of religious practice any
religious ritual
and here's the thing if it's something
that you would do normally that does not
count as skin in the game
and so keeping kosher is a sign of
religious fealty me eating more
vegetables is not a sign of religious
fealty because that is a rational thing
to do if i wish to preserve my health so
anything that could be come to through
simple
reasoning and rational processes that
doesn't demonstrate fealty that's just
you being a rational human being so for
example it doesn't demonstrate fealty to
the covet lockdown authoritarian mindset
to get vaccinated it really doesn't
right i've been vaccinated rhonda sansa
has been vaccinated donald trump as it
turns out has been triple vaccinated
that's not good enough you have to
demonstrate fealty to the idea this is
why the dictionary webster's dictionary
literally changed the definition of
anti-vaxx from does not like vaccines to
opposes vaccine mandates which is a very
different thing
i love the vaccines i'm very much
opposed to vaccine mandates
okay that's but
one of those things demonstrates field
seats to the cause and one of those
things doesn't getting the vax does not
demonstrate fealty to the cause because
that's in many cases a reasonable thing
to do supporting a bunch of nonsense
demonstrates fealty to the cause so when
you wonder i think those of us on the
right maybe a lot of us in the center
we've been wondering i don't understand
you guys are pursuing policies right now
that are completely disconnected from
the available data on the ground in fact
we know they're not going to work now we
think they're not going to work we know
they're not going to work because
they've not worked anywhere their mass
mandates have not worked anywhere in
terms of suppressing the virus
they're certainly not going to work
against omicron
your attempts to force five-year-olds to
vaccinate in order to stop the spread
it's not going to work we know it's not
going to work because you've tried it
and it hasn't worked and yet you
continue to maintain that these are the
policies you wish to push
the only reason to do that is as a
signal of in-group
membership right it is the yamaka in the
to take the jewish example is the yamaka
of of covet cultness
it is the kashrut of covid cultness i'm
saying the jewish example just because
that's the the world that i know best
right you are creating
stricter and stricter rules and the more
strictly you perform these rules the
more you are demonstrating feel to
quote-unquote the science ironically in
order for you to demonstrate fealty to
quote the science you have to do stuff
that is wildly anti-scientific and has
nothing to do with the data
because when you believe that science is
an institution as opposed to a neutral
process for discovering truth
then you have to demonstrate demonstrate
fealty to the institution and that means
doing stuff on the basis of faith alone
right we have to commit works based on
faith and it can't be reasonable in fact
it's supposed to be unreasonable because
if you're willing to do the unreasonable
thing if you're willing to mask up your
three-year-old if you're willing to
never go to dinner again with anybody
that you love
you have truly demonstrated your field
tee to the cult and this makes you a
morally superior person by the way when
you talk to people who do all these
things and then they get covered they're
bewildered they really are i mean they
act as though
they act like sort of
people who don't understand religion
very well act after they do all of the
commandments and then somebody they know
gets cancer it's like i did all the
right things how could this happen
well the answer is maybe covet doesn't
play by your rules maybe your faith is
incorrect
maybe if your faith is reliant on the
idea that if you perform the requisite
rituals and perform the the human
sacrifices necessary in order to appease
the gods of tough science that coveted
will leave you alone and then that
doesn't happen maybe you should
re-examine your premise
but nobody's re-examining their premise
they're just doubling down
i think that we have converted so many
americans particularly in blue states to
this this
cultish behavior with regard to covid
and you have the high priesthood right
the high priesthood is the the anthony
fauci's in in new york the governor or
in new york city the mayor
joe biden
and they speak like religious figures
i mean they literally predict death upon
people who refused to abide by their
dicktots
and joe biden came out yesterday and joe
biden literally said
millions of unfacts face a winter of
illness and death okay now
as a descriptive matter
anybody who's unvex faces an additional
risk
okay that does not mean that if you are
unbacked you are definitely going to die
it also does not mean that if you have
prior natural immunity
you are going to get struck with this in
the same way that you would if you don't
have prior natural immunity
making no distinction between the the
unvaxxed who have prior natural immunity
and those who not is anti-scientific
but joe biden here is speaking like a
religious figure not like a scientific
figure
right you have sinned and you will be
punished i wonder why this guy's riding
in the low 40s in the approval ratings
here's the president of the united
states
we're unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death unvaccinated
for themselves their families and the
hospitals they'll soon overwhelm
okay let me just make this clear
for the unvaccinated omicron is less of
a threat than delta
so i think that most of the unvaccinated
should get facts i think the huge number
of them are in positions where they
require the vaccinations in order to
provide them top-notch protection
however the way that people are talking
about all of this
is designed to elicit not a rational
risk assessment that might result in a
vaccination it is designed to elicit a
hatred for the heretics it's designed to
create two classes of human beings in
the united states the vast and the
unvaxed but it's more than that it's
also that if you don't agree with joe
biden and are vast you're bad
because again they keep taking they keep
taking measures that have nothing to do
with stopping the spread of you can't
stop here's the thing you're not
stopping the spread of omicron just
gonna put it out there nothing you do
stops the spread of omicron nothing
okay you can you can do all of these
things you can mask up the wazoo you can
force everybody to get vast omicron is
coming and that's just the way it's
gonna be
and you're just gonna have to deal with
that because reality still exists i'm
looking up right now in real time
the the case loads in places like the uk
uk coveted cases
are are still spiking have they spiked
and they're continuing to spike
guess what they have
in the uk
high levels very high levels of
vaccination
okay guess what they had in south africa
very low levels of vaccination
they didn't have massive levels of death
in south africa
the only thing you can do with regard to
cova with regard to to omicron at this
point is delay but you're not going to
stop the spread
they're still operating under the same
assumptions as march 2020 and we know
those aren't going to work
it's incredible
they're not even mentioning what their
goals are here what are your goals
you're going to stop the spread of
omicron let's talk about some of the
measures that are now being undertaken
by the panicked and the measures that
are that are being undertaken by the pan
and by the panic are completely
unrelated to reality so here for example
is the mayor the brand new mayor of
boston the radical progressive michelle
wu who for a brief moment in time was
not beloved by progressives because
she's not minority enough right she's
asian she's not black this meant that
even though
she was a minority woman she was not
minority enough or for some of the
members of the progressive movement but
she definitely is wildly left so here
she is announcing an authoritarian
mandate proof of vaccination will now be
required to enter pretty much anywhere
for everybody over the age of 12.
now what's weird is that they've been
doing this in new york guess what they
have in new york that's right an omicron
spike here's michelle wu
today we're announcing that boston will
be implementing a requirement for proof
of covet 19 vaccination for certain
indoor spaces which we're calling our be
together initiative
be together we'll require proof of
vaccination to enter indoor dining
well three three categories just so you
can keep the count first indoor dining
including bars and restaurants
secondly indoor fitness venues such as
gyms and third indoor entertainment
recreational and event venues such as
theater shows or sports games
starting january 15th
customers or patrons ages 12 and up and
employees at these locations will be
required to show proof that they've
released received at least one dose of
the vaccine
and this will phase into requiring two
doses on february 15th
we're also setting dates for children to
be vaccinated to enter these spaces
beginning in march
so she's going to stretch that all the
way down presumably to five-year-olds in
boston now they've already tried this in
new york did it help
i mean when you have a policy the first
thing you should ask is do we have
precedent for this policy working
anywhere
and the answer is not so much the
orwellian name be together by the way
when she is deliberately separating
human beings is pretty impressive
it is called b together the b is for
boston so it's boston together or
something b to get except no one's
together because you're deliberately
attempting to separate them
now
we know that the vaccine is not stopping
omicron transmission we know this
right so that
right now a two dose pfizer vaccine
if you've gotten vaccinated twice and
you haven't had a booster in the recent
past according to the studies 33 percent
reduction in transmissibility
that's not going to stop community
spread we have communities spread nearly
everywhere
in the course of a couple of weeks
omicron took over the country
but you're pushing the same measures
anyway that you know won't work same
thing in chicago
according to nbc chicago mayor lori
lightfoot is expected to make a major
announcement on tuesday regarding the
city's fight against coven
it's pretty obvious that they're going
to start pushing vaccination proof for
places of leisure restaurants gyms and
other places this is what lori lightfoot
suggested
so now is the time to act and we will
okay and this is happening all over the
place in washington dc the mayor
reinstated an indoor mass mandate on
monday
so you got boston you got chicago you
got new york state
but
as we'll see it's amazing because the
cult still is going to at some point
there's one one problem for the cult and
the cult is going to have to allow
people to live or they're just going to
destroy their cities and they know it so
at the same exact time that they are
pushing the cult they understand that
the measures that they are demanding
from people are not going to be
particularly effective well that mixed
message is not going to help you
because either you have to have full
believership or noble leadership you
can't have both
meanwhile gensake announced that
president biden is going to speak on
tuesday he's going to speak today
about the virus he's and then she says
he's not going to speak about shutting
the country down he's going to scare the
unvaxxed because that's been working
super well again another policy
prescription that is completely useless
what if you scare the nvx what if we
just yell at them a lot yeah clearly
that's been working
i mean by the way that's been working so
poorly
that as we will see if you're president
trump and you announced your triple
backs people will boo you okay so here's
jen saki
for those who choose to remain
unvaccinated he'll issue a stark warning
and make clear unvaccinated individuals
will continue to drive hospitalizations
and deaths that is not trying to scare
people or maybe it is trying to make
clear to people in the country what the
risks are here of not being vaccinated
this is not a speech about locking the
country down this is a speech outlining
and being direct and clear with the
american people about the benefits of
being vaccinated vaccinated the steps
we're going to take to increase access
and to increase testing uh and uh the
risks posed to unvaccinated individuals
okay so uh this is not designed to work
how do you know it's not designed to
work because joe biden's been saying
this stuff for months and months and
months and months and um it doesn't work
he literally gave a speech a few months
ago in which he said he'd run out of
patience with the unvaccinated you know
what the unvaccinated said he said go
screw off old man they didn't care
and here's the thing i disagree with
many of the people who are unvaccinated
but you're not going to convince them by
yelling at them
you're not going
i've had many unvaccinated people in my
life that i have talked to about this
virus and what i've said to them with
regard to vaccination is let's look up
your risk factors let's look up your
chances of death with the virus and now
let's look up your chances of death with
the vaccine
and here's your risk reward ratio and
there may be some risks that we're not
taking into account you're right we
don't have long-term data meaning like
10-year data on a vaccine that was
developed a year ago what we do know is
what your risk is today of dying of
covid versus your risk today of dying
after you've taken the vaccine of covet
and maybe that risk differential is
great enough that you take the vaccine
that is the only way you're going to get
anybody to vaccinate and many of those
people are still going to say no and
then they're just going to have to live
with their decisions but they're not
again they're not really that concerned
with anything except the politics of the
cult this is why eddie glaud over at
msnbc is like yeah biden needs to get
tougher on the unvac what's he going to
do slap him around a little bit
does joe biden need to get tougher and
if getting tougher i mean tougher on the
unvaccinated in particular and if you
think he needs to get tougher what would
that look like
well i think he does and i think he
what i think at the heart of it are
vaccine mandates and we know that
there's a whole range of litigation
uh uh in this regard i think it has
everything to do with uh uh proving or
showing vaccination with regards to uh
flying or you know traveling via air and
the like he needs to get tougher
he needs to get tougher okay good luck
because guess what ain't none of that
going to make a difference you know what
else is not going to make a difference
mass testing mass testing is not going
to make a difference you know why
because everyone's going to get omicron
if you're asymptomatic and you're
testing you're wasting your time
okay this is
what do you do test and trace 300
million people
good luck it's not designed for any of
that we'll get some more of this in just
one moment so
i've been working pretty hard not
working out enough recently not not
having time to get to the gym and what
that means is that i have to work out at
home more well good news for me i have
an echelon echelon brings the gym home
when you're trying to reach your fitness
goals it can really help to have
world-class instructors choreographing
classes music from your favorite artist
a community of hundreds of thousands of
people who can give you that extra push
echelon will give you that echelon is
the affordable way to get the workout
equipment the workout community and an
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort of your own home echelon's
fitness app provides you thousands of
live and on-demand classes with great
music with echelon you can work out
anytime day or night and crush your
fitness goals it's super convenient at
the middle of the day and i have a lunch
break i can pop on that echelon machine
get in my workout the kids just went to
bed i didn't get a workout that day i
can jump on that echelon burn off a
bunch of calories
echelon's certified fitness instructors
are supportive engaging in fun they know
how to get you moving i really enjoy the
classes i've been doing it for months at
this point echelon's full range of
affordable workout equipment including
stationary bikes smart rollers sleek
fitness screens and the auto folding
treadmill are all connected to provide
the echelon experience right now for a
limited time podcast listeners get up to
800 bucks off msrp to get this exclusive
podcast discount text ben 281 81.81
again text my name ben to 81-8181 get up
to 800 bucks off msrp text spend
281-8181-818181
message and data rates may apply c terms
for details okay so
as you might expect
the the
blowback is not just
domestic in scope right because there
are crackdowns all over the world and
the blowback is international in scope
according to the uk daily mail scuffles
broke out at an anti-lockdown protest in
parliament square in britain as
thousands of protesters opposed to the
vaccine passports and plan b rules
clashed with police while the ministers
were considering more restrictions
it looks like a giant crowd and
that is no shock so you've seen that in
london
we've seen coveted protests in france
we've seen coveted protests in germany
in belgium
none of this is a giant shock because
people are sick of this and they don't
feel like their public health
authorities actually have a plan to get
out of it and maybe the reason they
don't feel like that is because their
public health authorities don't actually
have a plan they just have a bunch of
things that they're going to yell at you
there's yelling slogans at you at this
point so on the one hand just take dr
fauci for example because he is great
and sainted and we all have votive
candles to him and we have to offer
bird sacrifices and then read the
entrails after we burn them on the altar
of kovid for dr fauci
i mean i'm so annoyed with this guy at
this point go back and listen to my show
at the very beginning i was a defender
of fouchy at least in the sense that i
thought he was doing his best now i just
think that he's a political hack who has
no idea what he's doing but cannot stay
away from that little red light that
flashes at him while he's on the tv
it's it's an amazing thing so yesterday
he says we're never going to eradicate
covet okay well then might you explain
what you are attempting to do sir here
he was yesterday
if you look at the different phases of
an outbreak
from the bottom up we're never going to
eradicate this we've only eradicated one
virus in that small box
elimination may be too aspirational
okay so he says we're going to work on
control okay but you can't control
omicron we all know you can't control
omicron by the way i'm hearing so many
like right now they're so this is
actually really funny the nfl was going
to attempt what they called test to stay
so tested was the idea if somebody in
your room gets omicron then we have to
test everybody else in the room to see
if they also got omicron and if you test
clear you get to stay and then the nfl
realized wait a second everybody is
going to test positive for omicron and
will be completely asymptomatic so if we
just don't test them
then they won't have to go home so if
they're vast and they're asymptomatic
the nfl is not going to test them
anymore even if they were exposed to
omicron which makes sense because guess
what testing is not going to be the
solution here here is the solution you
ready i know it's two you ready here's
the solution
if you're symptomatic don't go to work
if you're symptomatic don't go to school
that's the whole we're done
that's literally the entire covered plan
how is that for you you think you can
handle that if you're symptomatic don't
go to work
if you are a person with significant
risk factors and you have no natural
immunity and you haven't been vaccinated
before
go get a vac if you wish to minimize
your own risk
those are all the things
i did that in less than 30 seconds was
that super duper difficult but they
can't they can't they cannot give up the
control because then you wouldn't be
showing fealty to the cult
so instead you have dr anthony fauci
putting together this bizarre
regimen
of intricate laws and regulations that
don't fit together in any logical way
it's all self-contradictory i mean it's
truly self-contradictory
you will see people say things like well
you know everyone around here has to
mask and the reason they have to ask is
because that will stop coverage like
wait hold on a second what kind of masks
well
you know cloth mask no cloth masks don't
work
but they'll say i've literally heard
this if we all wear cloth masks and then
one of us comes down with covid the rest
of us don't have to test
okay now you're assuming that cloth
masks work which they don't then you
hear well what if one of us comes down
with covid and then we test everybody
in order to stay because
if we if we don't do that then they
might come down with a mild
cold for the most part particularly
among children and then we might have to
shut down the school well who's shutting
down the school you you're the decision
makers see this is the part that totally
drives me nuts the entire
public health establishment has said
that covett is what is driving this
no
you are driving the actual real world
way that people are living with your
regulations kovid didn't do anything
cove it's a disease when i say covered
in it killed tons of people it made a
lot of people sick you are the ones who
decided who can work you are the ones
who decided whose businesses had to shut
down forever you're the ones who decided
whether my children have to wear masks
you're the ones who decided whether my
kids could even go to school it was you
the coveted virus did not decide
anything because kovit does not have a
brain kovet has no level of intent covet
cannot tell you to do anything all you
can do is look at the data and try to
formulate public policy but you're not
doing it based on the data
so instead you have anthony fauci
telling us that we have to mask on
airplanes literally forever he said that
yesterday you have to mask on airplanes
literally for all time despite the fact
that he cannot present one shred of data
that airplanes have been a chief vector
of transmission
then yesterday he said the vax and the
boosted should feel comfortable getting
together
he doesn't explain why he doesn't
present any data to suggest why this is
the case even though the vaccine and the
boosted have been passing this to one
another here we go
vaccinated and boosted people one of the
family members of vaccinated should feel
very comfortable
in getting together and enjoying a
holiday meal or a holiday get-together
why should we listen to you really why
if you're vaccinated and you're boosted
you can still pass it to one another hey
there's no evidence that the booster
stops transmission completely
maybe you should i mean he's been saying
you should vax and boost and mask
so which is it
uh here
so what's going to stop all of this
what's going to stop all this is reality
what's going to stop all this is the
actual reality by the way if you want to
stop all of this like on a regular level
reality you can be part of reality by
signing our petition against the joe
biden vax mandates which have now been
reinstated by the sixth circuit court of
appeals that are supposed to go into
effect for 80 million americans come
february sign our petition right now at
dailywire.com
do not comply we're at almost a million
signatures we're trying to get to a
million before christmas so please head
on over to dailywire.com should not
comply sign the petition
what's going to stop all of this is that
eventually democrats are going to have
to come to grips with the fact that the
cult is very unpopular it's popular with
its members and it's very unpopular with
everyone else because there are real
world consequences to the kind of
garbage you are preaching we'll get to
those real world consequences in just
one moment first one of the consequences
here is increasing gas prices right
we've seen supply chain bottlenecks
we have seen you know real problems in
terms of supply thanks to the biden
administration's bad oil policy
well if you would like to save on a tank
of gas which seems like a pretty major
thing right now perhaps you should check
out get upside it's a free app you can
pick up wherein listeners are making up
to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up you just
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now you
use promo code shapiro get a bonus 25
cents per gallon on your first fill up
that's up to 50 cents cash back don't
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using it get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cash back on your very first tank of gas
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two 300 bucks a month in cash
back there is no catch
the cash back gets added directly to
your account you can cash out anytime to
your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands just
download that free getupside app use
promo code shapiro to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cashback on your very first
tank of gas that is promo code shapiro
right now get that free get upside app
use promo code shapiro get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your very
first tank of gas already in just a
second we're going to talk about what
actually stops the left from from
continuing this forever and that is
reality because the reality is starting
to set in you can start to see little
hints of it just around the edges of
left-wing policy first we have big news
here at our daily wire south florida
offices our team right here in south
florida is growing we are searching for
a talented new producer to join us
support our efforts in the production of
all the new and exciting projects we
have going on you want to work on the
ben shapiro show this could be your shot
if you've got at least five years of
previous professional producer or line
producer experience strong skills in
leading and managing others if you're an
avid consumer of all things politics
news and pop culture this is the
opportunity on the dw team you've been
waiting for again this position is based
in our south florida offices not our
national offices down here with me in
south florida to learn more about the
position and apply and to view a full
list of our current openings at daily
wire please visit dailywire.com
careers also candace owens went to
mar-a-lago to interview president trump
they discussed everything from the
potential for another run in 2024 that's
why he didn't pardon whistleblowers what
he really thinks about alec baldwin the
interview is fascinating it streams
tonight 9 p.m eastern 8 pm central only
at dailywire.com so if you're not a
member yet now would be the time to join
if you dig candace head on over to
yesweecandis.com she now has some
awesome candace merch at that link
also if you missed it we have a brand
new show it is called the search because
it really is just about the search for
truth and meaning it is me sitting down
with some of my most stimulating friends
we sit down over a cup of coffee and we
just talk for like an hour and a half
two hours and we just go through life
and family and like all the things that
really matter it's it's not an interview
show it's just
you're a fly on the wall in a
conversation between me and some of my
most interesting friends the first
episode is available right now it is
fantastic it's my good friend jordan
peterson you can check that out right
now at daily dailywire.com
there's even more guys okay here's the
even more the daily wire is now making
it easier than ever to listen to all of
your favorite shows on the go with our
launch of listen on the website and the
dw app listen is here to make soaking up
our content as convenient as possible
with a limited ad audio experience
whether it's morning wire on your work
commute the latest top takes from your
favorite house exploring our growing
radio theater all of that is available
to you right now we've made sure it's
available to members and non-members
everyone can check that out you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so just to recap briefly here is
what your democratic mayors governors
and president want joe biden announced
today he wants 500 million more tests of
asymptomatic people which just means
that you're going to get a lot of
positives
you can't stop the transmission
you're not going to stop the community
spread this is completely worthless it
is a complete waste of time all it's
going to do is shut down the economy
shut down schools shut down society
that's all it's going to do because what
you're going to do is you're going to
mandate that everybody who comes back
positive now quarantine
if you mandate that everybody who's
positive quarantine based on
asymptomatic
disease
possession you're going to shut down the
entire society okay then you have
vaccine passports all of that is
completely useless because guess what
the vaccine are transmitting this then
you have the vast mandates everybody who
wants to get faxed is capable of getting
facts everybody who doesn't want to get
facts is not going to get vast
so
none of these things are geared toward
reality they are all geared toward
members of your government gripping hard
to the idea that they are the ones who
can fix everything they cannot fix this
they can't they are lying to you they
have been lying to you the entire
pandemic
but they cannot come to grips with the
fact that their religion the religion of
government is a false religion it is a
cult it is a pseudo religion in which
you are meant to sacrifice your life and
your freedom on the altar of idiocy
because joe biden a doddering old fool
tells you to do a thing and anthony
faucin incompetent government bureaucrat
tells you to do a thing you're supposed
to do it without asking for the
underlying data
my patience is gone okay he says his p
joe biden says his patience with the
with the unvax is over my patience with
these morons is done i have no patience
for them whatsoever now
they have they've ruined lives they've
destroyed businesses they've led to a
vast increase in mental illness among
young people they have led to to young
children
changing the trajectory of their
educational career
they've shut down hundreds of thousands
of businesses
they've killed tens of thousands of
people in additional opioid overdoses
and they've done all of this without
stopping the spread
and then they maintain that you are the
faithless one you are the bad one if you
don't listen to them
you know they can go get
my patience is done with them and guess
what
so is most americans
i know that in the media they love this
kind of stuff in the media they're still
shutting down everything major media
corporations on all sides are doing vax
mandates major media corporations are
pushing the panic button
that's because they are part of an
elitist society in which they get to
work but you don't
most of these people
they don't care about
the the strictures on children many of
them don't have children and if they do
have children they're sending them to a
hoity-toity private school where maybe
they're unmasked
okay but they don't have to worry about
inflation many of them are very wealthy
the people who are making the rules are
not abiding by the rules but that's not
the point you're supposed to abide by
the rules
and the only thing that's going to stop
this is serious resistance by the
american public in the form of votes
and that is going to happen because
right now central banks are talking
about how this new omicron variant
basically the government response to it
is going to destroy markets
according to the wall street journal the
omicron variant is circling the globe
closing borders sparking new
restrictions on economic activity yet
central banks instead of loosening
monetary policy to prop up their
economies are moving to unwind stimulus
and raise interest rates the moves
reflect a new thinking among policy
makers about the pandemic's economic
effects central bank officials worry
that rather than simply threatening to
curtail economic growth a surge in kovi
19 cases could also prolong high
inflation
in the past week the federal reserve the
bank of england and the european central
bank all moved to tighten monetary
policy in response to inflation concerns
when the pandemic first became
widespread governments locked down their
economies and blew money into them now
they're afraid that they're going to
create supply chain shortages again
because of omicron because of their
shutdowns
and that will create additional
inflation
as it turns out that once you enter into
the control loop there's a control loop
okay here's how it works we can control
the virus all we have to do is control
your life oh man that had the unintended
consequence of really screwing up the
economy well here's the thing we can
control the economy all we have to do is
control the monetary supply oh man well
that seems like that had a really
unintended consequence in terms of
inflation well here's the good news we
can control inflation all we have to do
is taper
oh man this is having some really bad
consequences in terms of unemployment
well here's the good news in order to
combat unemployment we can completely
restructure the american economy oh man
that's having some really bad
consequences probably in order to do
that we can exercise control over the
american economy with even more top-down
regulation well a certain point it turns
out that the spiral of garbage is going
to be stopped by the american voter and
you're starting to see inklings of this
among members of the left so for example
joseph allen associate professor and
director of the healthy buildings
program at harvard t.c chan school of
public health has a piece in the new
york times today titled we learned our
lesson last year do not close schools
oh did you learn your lesson
fascinating
as the american academy of pediatrics
stated in a report released this month
quote the available data indicate covet
19 associated hospitalization
hospitalization and death is uncommon in
children there's also promising news
regarding long covenant kids a large
meta-analysis published last month shows
kids who tested positive for covid have
rates of persistent symptoms that are
similar to those who tested negative
and when there were differences there
were small they were small
the early evidence from outside the u.s
suggests kids will remain at low risk
during omicron as well
the latest data from south africa shows
school-age kids five to 19 had the
lowest hospitalization of any age group
even with the omicron uptick the
hospitalization rate is four to six per
000.
so maybe we shouldn't close the schools
because that has some really bad
ramifications
well weird that the new york times is
now willing to print this opinion after
spending you know two years basically
going along to get along
and meanwhile
same day same paper dr j varma professor
at wild cornell medicine
epidemiologist he's suggesting
that we have to take some measures that
are not quite as restrictive as maybe
some of the vaccine lockdown
folks would have you suggest
they say
he says that we'll need to redefine
people as up-to-date or fully vaccinated
if they have their initial shots plus a
booster which is pretty controversial
considering that you still have b-cell
and t-cell immunity if you're a young
person the purpose of a booster is to
increase the antibodies in your
bloodstream that is particularly
relevant for people who are
immunocompromised for whom your immune
system's response based on t-cell and b
cell memory is going to be a little bit
longer means it takes longer for your
immune system to kick in and send out
the fighters to go kill the virus
or if you're if you're old boosters for
30 year olds the data on that is really
skimpy okay but here is the here's the
part that's pretty amazing okay even
this guy who's a real
kind of lockdown fanatic he says
isolation periods for vaccinated people
who test positive and no longer have
symptoms need to be shortened from the
currently recommended 10 days to around
5 days
since levels of coronavirus decline
rapidly in vaccinated people who are
infected people with breakthrough
infections will be able to return to
their daily lives faster even though a
small percentage may still be infectious
so he's admitting you're going to go
back and you're going to infect people
okay but you know what we still have to
we still have to do what we have to do
he says unlike in 2020 all jurisdictions
need to recognize
that in-person school is as essential to
society as hospitals
okay so
they've decided they're not going to go
all the way and just recognize that the
public policy needs to be geared toward
living with the virus and just dealing
with it they're never going to recognize
that because we'd undercut their entire
perspective but but they're going to
start to recognize we can't shut down
businesses and we can't shut down
schools well if you don't want to shut
down schools here's what that means you
can't test the asymptomatic period end
of story
it means that you cannot rely on cloth
masks as the all-purpose solution
because that's incredibly silly and
surgical masks either
okay when it came to surgical and cloth
mask data from that malaysian study
which is still the biggest study real
world study with regard to masks it
showed that for people under the age of
50 there was no differential for cloth
and surgical masks the only differential
was for kn95s and n95 you're not going
to make small children where n95s are
can 95s nor should you because again
their risk factors are unbelievably low
even for omicron that means four to six
kids your child's chances of being
hospitalized
for omicron if you look at that south
african data one in twenty five thousand
one in twenty five thousand
your kid has a better shot of of being
severely injured on a slide today
in all likelihood
okay so
eventually reality kicks in and these
people are going to have to get on board
you can help make that happen that is
why resistance is necessary i'm not
talking by the way here about not
getting the vaccine
again i think you should make a personal
decision based on your health factors i
think for the vast majority of people
that means you should get the vaccine
but it does mean that you should be
resisting vax mandates
if you are a business owner you should
not be going along to get along with
regard to the government you should be
resisting resisting mass mandates
all this crap has to end
or the cult wins
okay meanwhile
the democratic party is in a spiral of
hatred and reaper and
and
hate and recriminations because joe
manchin said the same thing he's been
saying all along which i'm not going to
sign on to a five trillion dollar bill
so yesterday the white house was ripping
on mansion and then shinsaki was asked
about ripping on mansion and she said no
regerts got a big tattoo across her neck
that said no regards here is jen saki
white house press secretary
[Music]
is there any regret uh within the white
house or within discussions with
democratic leadership just about how
this negotiation went given that
statement from him that he feels that
he's been badgered and beaten
well that certainly is not our objective
never has been our objective but
our objective is getting this
legislation passed and reminding
the american people and all people who
uh could vote for it what the stakes are
so no we don't have regrets about
aggressively communicating about it and
making sure people understand that if we
don't pass this legislation costs for
the american people will go up and
economic growth projections will not go
in the right direction
regards no regrets she's got no regrets
at all
uh i i'm amused by the fact that the
democratic party is now using republican
talking points with regard to this bill
it's going to lower your it's going to
lower your costs it's going to stop
inflation and good luck with those
arguments guys meanwhile joe manchin
fired back he's like yeah lady um
i'm from a state called west virginia
that your president lost by 40 points so
no
i'm not blaming anybody i knew where
they were and i knew what they could and
could not do
they just never realized it because they
figured surely to god we can move one
person sure that we can badger and beat
one person up surely we can get enough
protesters to make that person
uncomfortable enough they'll just say
okay i'll vote for anything just quit
well guess what i'm from west virginia
i'm not from where they're from and they
can just beat the living crap out of
people and think they'll be submissive
period
okay so um there's joe manchin this is
over the the biden white house they're
trying now they're trying to claw back
today they've been like well you know
joe biden personally didn't insult your
imagination you think mansion cares like
joe biden has this great wonderful
relationship with joe biden yeah good
luck with that joe biden joe manchin
he's like you know the reason why i
rejected their bills because they kept
giving me the same bill over and over
and over and they just kept lying about
it
the same bill i have in front of me
right now that they kept putting in
front of me was the same six trillion
dollar bill from the beginning the only
thing that changed was the time element
which they would pay for things and i
said that's just in genuine to tell
someone's getting a tax credit it goes
away in one year
okay so meanwhile the progressives in
the party they're thinking like should
we just get rid of joe manchin like
please keep doing this please keep
whittling your party down so
representative pramila jayapal she uh
she's one of the leaders of the
progressive caucus uh and uh and she
says you know joe biden told me that joe
manchin was committed i'm so surprised
i'm so shocked really are you though
because um you shouldn't be
it was a complete stunner a complete
shocker because the president told me
that senator manchin had committed to
that framework that the president
unveiled to us right before he went to
cop26 um and that that was the framework
that the progressive caucus then
endorsed
all of which prompted wolf blitzer to
ask gianpaul do you think the mansion
even belongs in your party mansion
apparently is considering going
independent
which in west virginia is a smart move
didn't hurt bernie sanders to be an
independent socialist in vermont so if
manchin goes independent he will still
win elections in west virginia then he
gets to be the swing vote by the way if
joe manchin becomes a republican he
loses all power right then he's just
another republican from a red state and
probably not the most right-wing
republican in west virginia like not
even close because he's kind of a
democrat right so him going independent
is still a real possibility and then he
gets to decide every single election who
he caucuses with the republicans or the
democrats but here's will flitzer
suggesting that the democrats expel him
yeah please go for it guys do it
senator manchin says he'd like to think
there's still a place for him in the
democratic party do you think he still
belongs to the democratic party
go for it man really do it
well i mean if aoc had her way they
would aoc yesterday she can always be
counted on for the stupidest possible
analysis of any given situation because
she of course has the brain wattage of a
frying pan uh she says that these you
know the big problem here is that the
senate is an old boys club
someone should tell that to kirsten
cinema who's the other vote to
not do this here here's aoc
what we really need to do is crack down
on the senate which operates like an old
boys club that has a couple of gals in
it that have managed to break through
and we need to actually institute some
institution we actually need to
implement some institutional discipline
if people want to threaten to to block
ambassadorships if they want to threaten
dysfunction they actually need to show
up and do it
man do it man this party is so
dysfunctional so
the party's platform come 2022 is
coveted shutdowns mass testing mass
panic
high inflation
ripping on the independents who won't
vote for your massive stupid bills
and then jabbering to msnbc
2022 is gonna be real bad for democrats
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime as i've suggested please
head on over to dailywear.com do not
comply we are very close to one million
signatures the sixth circuit court of
appeals has lifted a stay on the vax
mandate we are making a direct appeal to
the supreme court right now right we are
we are the chief plaintiff in this
particular case so please help us out
dailywire.com do not comply sign the
petition help us get to a million
signatures coming up soon the matt wall
show airs 1 30 p.m eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show